[Music]
we have seen in the previous video that
a cell cycle has two major phases do you
remember the names of the two phases
that's right
interphase and M phase we have seen that
the interphase lasts longer in duration
compared to the M phase the major reason
being that the interphase deals with
preparation for the actual division
which occurs in the M phase now in this
video let's have a look at both these
phases in detail since these phases are
quite complex we divide them in sub
stages to understand them better let's
begin with the interphase first here is
an image that depicts the complete
interphase in general as we can see the
phase has three stages let's begin each
stage step by step the first stage of
the interface is the first gap phase
abbreviated as g1 phase this is the
first phase occurring in interphase
hence the name first gap phase it
corresponds to the interval between the
M phase of the previous cycle and the S
phase of the current cycle since this is
the first stage of the interface that is
the first stage of the preparatory phase
and the face which precedes synthesis of
DNA what do you think will be the
activities of the cell just think about
it well as the cell is metabolically
active it grows in size in the g1 phase
all the organelles duplicate in this
phase and the building blocks which will
be required in later stages are made by
the cell it is important to note that
the g1 phase does not involve DNA
replication now let's move to the second
stage of interphase which is this
synthesis phase abbreviated as S phase
as the name suggests there will be
synthesis of something and what will
that something be the most crucial part
of each cell that's the nucleus along
with the genetic material with it will
get synthesis
that is duplicated so the s-phase takes
up the charge of the DNA replication now
along with the nucleus there is one more
important organelle that gets duplicated
in the S phase do we know this bundle of
threads present in the cell that is
called the centrosome this bunch
contains smaller organelles called the
centrioles placed within usually at
right angles
they are made up of microtubules which
help in releasing the threads required
for separating sister chromatids later
we will have a detailed look at this
process in our upcoming videos for now
all we need to know is that these
threads are important for the cell
division and for this reason duplication
of the bundle containing these threads
is also important
this happens in the S phase so the S
phase takes up the responsibility of
duplicating the contents inside the
nucleus and the centrosome present in
the cytoplasm simultaneously what next
then the next step in the process of the
interface is the second gap phase
abbreviated as g2 phase this phase
allows the cell to grow more along with
the enlargement in the cell size the
cell also makes more proteins and
organelles the most important function
of this phase is that it prepares the
cell for mitosis this phase helps the
cell to prepare for the actual cell
division in the M phase so now are we
set to study the next phase that is the
M phase no not yet we are yet to study
one more intermediate phase a stage
which can be entered post the M phase of
one cycle and before the g1 phase of the
next cycle there is a phase called the
g0 phase in between so why don't we talk
about this phase in the beginning before
the g1 phase well the cells may or may
not opt to enter this phase the cells
may enter the g0 phase or may directly
enter the g1 phase after the cell
division and what factor
besides this well there are several
intrinsic and extrinsic factors like
resource availability or nutritional
deprivation which can force the self to
enter this g0 phase but what exactly
happens in this face this face was
classically thought to be only a resting
phase as the cell is metabolically
active but does not show tendency to
divide further however recent studies
suggest different names for this phase
if the cells enter the g0 phase such
that they returned to g1 phase after
some time then it's called the quiescent
stage that means the cells will be
metabolically active but only arrest
it's further division however they can
re-enter the g1 phase as and when
possible
so this kind of phase where the g0 phase
can be reversed to enter g1 will be the
quiescent stage but if the cells enter
the g0 phase irreversibly then they are
said to enter the cinesín phase that
means the cells will only be
metabolically active but never show the
tendency to divide further hence this
phase is called cinesín phase the one
from where there is no return to verts
further division so depending upon the
extrinsic and the intrinsic factors the
cells enter the g0 phase which is a
metabolically active phase the only
difference is that the cells do not
divide further either for some amount of
time or permanently so g0 phase is the
phase where the cell division halts
keeping the cell highly active otherwise
now that we've had a look at all the
important phases in the interphase let's
have a look at the next important part
of the cell cycle that is the M phase
this could be mitosis or meiosis
depending upon the type of cells to a
surprise even this M phase shows
different stages let us begin with
mitosis and its of phases in our
upcoming videos
do subscribe to our channel and happy
learning
[Music]
you